Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Ho passato gli ultimi
dieci anni in spiaggia.
E prima che cominciate
a invidiarmi un po' troppo,
in realtà li ho passati
più a raccogliere spazzatura
e a cercare di capire
che cosa era tutta questa plastica
che trovavo in spiaggia,
da dove veniva,
e come cercare di fermarla.
C'erano molte cose che non mi quadravano,
e non mi quadrano ancora adesso:
come sia arrivato
un frigorifero in spiaggia,
un telefono, o un asciugacapelli.
E quello che veramente
non riuscivo a capire
è come mai così tante persone
andassero in spiaggia
a pulirsi le orecchie.
Questo veramente non riuscivo a spiegarlo.
Quello che ho capito, invece,
è che di gran parte della plastica
che troviamo in spiaggia,
solo poca parte di questa
plastica arriva dal mare.
La gran parte, invece,
viene dalle coste e viene dall'entroterra.
E una parte importante,
la metà degli oggetti
che troviamo in spiaggia,
sono in realtà oggetti
usa e getta di uso quotidiano.
E sono un po' la somma
di tanti piccoli comportamenti quotidiani
che abbiamo, ciascuno di noi,
moltiplicati per milioni di volte.
E allora, ora finalmente
il mare di plastica
è diventato un argomento
di grande attualità, per fortuna,
anche se sembra che il problema,
l'allarme che suscita,
sia più rivolto alle isole
di plastica del Pacifico
piuttosto che al mare di casa nostra.
E allora, come diceva Luca giustamente,
una cosa abbiamo capito anche,
o per lo meno l'ho capita io,
che la plastica
è un materiale meraviglioso.
Non dobbiamo demonizzarlo.
Le nostre automobili, i nostri aerei,
adesso sono leggerissimi,
consumano pochissimo, poco carburante.
La plastica ha salvato tanti animali;
pensate alle tartarughe e agli elefanti.
Salva anche le nostre vite.
Il problema non è la plastica:
il problema è come noi
stiamo usando la plastica,
che è un materiale fantastico,
utilissimo, leggero, resistente
e lo usiamo per degli usi, appunto,
che si esauriscono in pochissimi minuti.
E poi è talmente poco costosa
che ci dimentichiamo, e non facciamo caso,
o attenzione, a come la smaltiamo.
E allora, da questa idea
del cercare di capire
come uscire da questo problema,
abbiamo creato un progetto europeo
in cui vi è una grande alleanza
fra tutti gli amanti del mare,
fra tutti i velisti, subacquei,
diportisti, pescatori, sportivi,
i ragazzi delle scuole,
gli insegnanti, tutti i cittadini.
E a tutti stiamo chiedendo
di fare tre cose molto semplici:
non buttare; raccogliere;
e cercare di usare
meno plastica usa e getta.
Sono, insomma, delle cose
di estrema semplicità,
e forse addirittura banali.
Però andiamo a vedere un attimo
che cosa vuol dire "non buttare":
per esempio, "non buttare"
vuol dire "fare più attenzione".
Io sono certa che nessuno di voi
butti i sacchetti della spazzatura
per le strade, vero?
Però, quando andiamo in spiaggia
e lasciamo un sacchetto
in un contenitore strapieno,
guardate che è esattamente la stessa cosa,
perché basta che passi un cane,
un gatto, un uccello e apra il sacchetto,
e a quel punto tutta
la spazzatura che è contenuta
si spargerà e andrà a finire in mare.
In questi 18 minuti di chiacchierata,
in Italia si fumeranno
due milioni e mezzo di sigarette.
E a giudicare dai marciapiedi,
come li vediamo in tutte
le città o nelle spiagge,
molte di queste sigarette
vanno a finire per terra.
Allora, fumatori, per piacere,
fate attenzione,
perché i mozziconi di sigarette
sono di plastica,
intrisi di sostanze tossiche,
e quindi ci vuole veramente molto poco
per eliminare uno dei rifiuti
più frequenti sulle spiagge:
mozziconi e accendini.
Questi sembrano oggetti
assolutamente innocui, allegri,
colorati e divertenti -
sempre plastica sono.
Una parte importante, addirittura un terzo
dei rifiuti che troviamo in spiaggia,
derivano da persone che sono andate
in spiaggia a divertirsi;
quindi sono giocattoli, penne, occhiali,
creme solari e cose del genere,
O merendine.
Quindi attenzione, di nuovo:
con un po' più di attenzione,
possiamo eliminare
una parte importante dei rifiuti.
Ma l'attenzione verso la pulizia del mare
deve partire anche dall'entroterra.
I palloncini ce lo dimostrano:
tutto quello che va su,
naturalmente poi scoppia e cade giù.
E quando sono in mare,
i palloncini assumono la stessa forma
e le stesse movenze di meduse o calamari,
che sono il cibo preferito
di pesci, tartarughe e uccelli.
Quindi, palloncini sì,
ma non facciamoli volare, per favore.
Ma l'attenzione per il mare
parte dalle nostre case.
Nei nostri gabinetti, per piacere,
non dobbiamo buttare nulla,
perché questi sono alcuni dei rifiuti
che troviamo più spesso sulle spiagge.
E quindi abbiamo risolto [l'enigma]:
non erano tutte persone che andavano
in spiaggia a pulirsi le orecchie,
erano tutte persone
che si pulivano le orecchie
e poi gettavano i bastoncini
non nel cestino, ma nel gabinetto.
Quindi, [con] un poco di attenzione in più
riusciamo ad eliminare
una parte importante di rifiuti.
Dalle nostre docce parte, quotidianamente,
una nuvola di frammenti
di plastica verso il mare:
sono gli esfolianti.
Guardate da queste fotografie
quanta plastica è contenuta
in un singolo flacone.
Anche qua - per fortuna,
dall'anno prossimo saranno proibiti;
ma già da subito
possiamo evitare di comprarli,
semplicemente guardando l'etichetta,
e se c'è scritto "polietilene'' evitiamo.
Questa è la strada preferita per i rifiuti
per finire in mare: i nostri fiumi.
Quindi particolare attenzione
dobbiamo prestare
quando siamo vicino
ai fiumi, per l'appunto.
Giusto per farvi vedere
lo stillicidio continuo di spazzatura
che c'è, che arriva in mare
attraverso i fiumi, è questo:
basta un tappo che si forma,
un tappo sotto le arcate di un ponte,
e vediamo effettivamente quanta plastica,
dall'entroterra, arriva al mare.
E infine l'attenzione che dobbiamo porre
anche quando vogliamo svuotare
le nostre cantine:
siamo sicuri che il dondolo della nonna,
o il triciclo di nostro nipote,
vada a finire veramente
all'isola ecologica
e non venga abbandonato
sotto il primo ponte?
Attenzione a chi affidiamo
i nostri oggetti.
Raccogliere è importante,
perché nessun paese al mondo
ha le capacità economiche
di andare a pulire il mare.
Il momento migliore,
per pulire una spiaggia,
è d'inverno, quando ci sono le burrasche.
E perché dobbiamo raccogliere?
Perché abbiamo ormai, veramente,
testimonianze infinite
dei danni che la plastica
possa fare agli animali.
Che ci si infilano dentro,
o si intrappolano, mangiano, soffocano,
per non parlare poi di altri impatti:
quanto costa ripulire le nostre spiagge?
Sono un danno per la navigazione:
i rifiuti sono veramente -
Noi ci stiamo focalizzando tanto
sulle isole di plastica del Pacifico
senza renderci conto che,
nel nostro Mediterraneo,
c è la stessa concentrazione
di microplastiche
che c'è in queste famigerate isole.
E il perché è presto detto:
il nostro mare è un lago,
tutto quello che c'è
finito dentro è ancora lì.
E se non lo vediamo, è semplicemente
perché si è frantumato.
E quindi, raccogliamo degli oggetti
finché sono ancora interi,
perché sennò, se li lasciamo in spiaggia,
si frantumeranno sotto l'azione
del sole, del sale e delle onde,
fino a frammenti così piccoli
che poi, a quel punto,
è veramente impossibile recuperarli.
E non pensate che questi
siano più innocui:
anzi, forse sono ancora
più subdoli e più pericolosi,
perché poi alla fine diventano
a portata di bocca del plancton,
che è il primo anello
della catena alimentare.
E quindi raccogliamo. Raccogliamo da soli.
Sergio ci ha appena detto:
portiamoci due sacchetti,
quando andiamo a fare il bagno.
Coinvolgiamo i nostri amici.
E per fortuna, nel nostro grande progetto
abbiamo coinvolto tanti subacquei,
perché se ci sembra orrendo
quello che abbiamo trovato in spiaggia,
e quello che avete visto in spiaggia,
in realtà la gran parte dei rifiuti
si trova sul fondo del mare.
Quindi i sommozzatori sono gli unici
che riescono ad andare
a pulire sul fondo del mare.
Ma se fare attenzione e raccogliere
sono due cose fondamentali,
la cosa più importante in assoluto
è il ripensare il nostro rapporto
con la plastica.
Senza essere talebani: in realtà,
io sono probabilmente vestita di plastica;
però la metà dei rifiuti
che troviamo in spiaggia è usa e getta.
E di nuovo: noi stiamo utilizzando
un materiale che è virtualmente eterno
per degli utilizzi che si esauriscono
in pochissimo tempo.
Ci siamo un po' ubriacati
di questo materiale
che è allegro e comodissimo
nella vita di tutti i giorni.
Dobbiamo però imparare a utilizzarlo
per quegli impieghi per i quali
un materiale così eterno,
da una vita così lunga,
sia effettivamente giustificato.
Quindi ciascuno deve cercare,
nella vita di tutti i giorni,
di trovare il modo per diminuire
l'uso di plastica usa e getta,
sostituendola con materiali
tipo il vetro, ad esempio.
Ma attenzione, che la bioplastica
è una soluzione, ma non è "la" soluzione.
Perché un sacchetto di questi
che vada a finire in mare -
loro si decompongono in condizioni
di compostaggio industriale.
Se invece questo finisce in mezzo al mare,
ci metterà mesi, se non anni,
a distruggersi,
e questo nel frattempo,
se un animale [lo] incontra
e se lo mangia, è spacciato lo stesso.
Sulle spiagge troviamo
tantissime bottiglie e tappi di bottiglia.
E questo è uno dei rifiuti
che possiamo più facilmente eliminare.
Ogni italiano, ciascuno di noi, di voi,
seduto in questa sala,
consuma in media 200 litri
di acqua in bottiglia all'anno,
E questo in un paese, come l'Italia,
dove l'acqua mediamente è buonissima.
Quindi è un modo molto semplice:
usiamo una borraccia,
ed evitiamo di usare e di comprare
tutta quest'acqua in bottiglia.
Ed è un modo molto rapido
per abbattere il nostro uso
di plastica usa e getta.
Ma c'è chi mi dice: "Ma perché?
Se io la riciclo, la mia bottiglietta?".
E allora... la bottiglietta di plastica,
la plastica delle bottigliette d'acqua,
non tornerà mai ad essere,
una volta riciclata,
di nuovo una bottiglietta;
diventerà qualcos'altro,
tanto più se la bottiglietta
d'acqua era colorata.
Quella plastica diventerà
un sacchetto della spesa,
un pile o una panchina.
Ma di quante panchine abbiamo bisogno noi?
E poi alla fine comunque andrà smaltita,
e quindi non facciamo altro
che portare più in là
il momento in cui dovremo
smaltire questa plastica.
La realtà è che noi non siamo in grado
di smaltire tutta questa spazzatura,
tutti questi rifiuti che stiamo generando.
E quindi la soluzione fondamentale
è quella di diminuire.
Diminuire gli imballaggi, soprattutto:
cerchiamo di comprare sfuso
il più possibile.
Ricordiamoci di quando usavamo il sapone,
anziché il sapone liquido.
Cerchiamo di evitare
situazioni tipo queste,
che sono francamente assurde.
Allora basta veramente poco,
basta un po' di consapevolezza
per diminuire il nostro uso
e abuso di plastica.
Queste sono solo alcune delle mille idee
che si possono avere
per andare in questa direzione.
Basta soltanto questo per salvare il mare?
Ovviamente no,
perché un problema così complesso
non ha una singola soluzione.
Il problema della plastica in mare
deriva dal fatto che abbiamo
una gestione dei rifiuti sbagliata,
a volte illegale,
certamente non sufficiente;
però abbiamo visto che una parte
importante dei rifiuti
la generiamo noi nel nostro
comportamento quotidiano.
E quindi, senza di noi,
senza un impegno nostro quotidiano,
per esempio come questo,
la situazione di certo non si risolve.
La buona notizia, come vedete,
è che veramente basta poco,
basta un po' di consapevolezza.
E allora -
negli ultimi due anni,
da quando è partito questo progetto,
abbiamo coinvolto più di 10.000 persone,
che hanno raccolto
più di dieci tonnellate di cose.
Immaginate se arrivassimo a 100.000
persone, quanto riusciremmo a fare.
Stiamo aiutando il Governo italiano
e l'Unione Europea
a semplificare la questione dei rifiuti,
e stiamo aiutando i pescatori
a riportare i rifiuti
che raccolgono nelle loro reti a mare.
Abbiamo incontrato migliaia di bambini
che hanno fatto la loro promessa al mare,
dal non lanciare i palloncini
a non usare mai più
bicchieri di plastica usa e getta.
Abbiamo convinto tre sindaci
a bandire il lancio dei palloncini;
e anche grazie al nostro lavoro
lo Stato italiano ha proibito l'uso
dei bastoncini per le orecchie di plastica
all'inizio di quest'anno,
e l'anno prossimo bandirà
le microplastiche nei cosmetici.
E allora basta questo?
Non basta, dobbiamo continuare.
Certo, se avessimo iniziato 20 anni fa,
a quest'ora sarebbe stato
tutto molto più facile.
Però c è un proverbio
cinese, meraviglioso,
che dice: "Il momento migliore
per piantare un albero, e avere l'ombra,
era 20 anni fa;
il secondo, il prossimo
momento, è questo".
Grazie.
(Applausi).